hey guys my name is Jess I'm here with
Dan and later Ed's to tell you about the
news that's been happening this week and
we're making at all we're not we're
absolutely not making it it's not
scripted though it is unscripted but we
are not making it up we are making it up
very important is completely made up
fake news massive news and fall out this
week Jess tell me all about no well yeah
it is kind of massive news I mean when
you lost III 2016 that there was a full
out for VR demo did a bunch of people
got to play now Todd Howard just come
out to tell us that is coming to e3 this
year and it's gonna blow our minds shot
how it is said fallout 4 is the most
incredible thing you've ever seen in
your life hold on it gets better you
can't even imagine what it's like
playing in VR and how realistic it looks
and everywhere you turn your head it's
going to blow your mind it is the
craziest thing you've ever seen now if
you did catch the full out for VR demo
last year you had to teleport around
from place to place so you were the red
rocket servo stations that's petrol
station not in Australian and basically
you were fending off against bandits and
things like that you could shoot you
could raise your arm to look at your
pip-boy not entirely sure if the
teleporting mechanic is going to be the
only way you can move around but for
what we know now that looks like it's
definitely gonna be an option you know
what comes from the sky water yes it
does yeah you know what else you're
where you're going with it you think was
likes water you niantic with working one
go because they're having a water
festival right now when I celebrate I
don't know what is cool I guess so
they're having a limited time event
which runs until March 29th where
there's increased sort of encounter
rates for squirtle totodile and magic
are for some all stupid or I mean I
don't have enough magic arts at this
point right yeah but everyone likes car
whenever like set a doll because
everyone loves starters and this week
they also introduced shiny pokemon once
you know what train you Pokemon on it so
in pokemon games there's a chance
that you might encounter what's got a
shiny pokemon which is a Pokemon that
it's sort of glints and they're just a
different color okay but they're just
super frickin rare can I pay with
real-world money to get these cosmetic
one no no they're not cosmetic they're
just like a rare catch like Oh Korea
breed which hardcore pokemon fans are
really excited about we do encounter on
pokemon it's a different color maybe
just hang onto it until that trading
feature comes late trading feature comes
in and sell up the cash money I've don't
off the gas money so then what's
happening in shooters you tend to give
us a lowdown on what's happening every
Friday so what's happening it's not fun
dates it's not worth based sort of now
but destiny 2 has been linked in some
capacity some posters were posted on an
Italian site showing the new guardians
and destiny to actually having the title
of get ready for it destiny to CEO of
Activision Eric Hirshberg did come out
recently in an earnings call and say
that they have a huge announcement
planned Podesta me too and also they're
trying to capture the existing destiny
player as well as the more casual game
player also according to the poster the
release date is going to be September 8
this year which is really soon at
another poster had a beta better on it
so obviously that oh boy and all this is
much like destiny one that had a beta
around III 2014 I believe and then it
came out September 9 2014 so I think
there might be some validity to do this
there's been some controversy over the
fact that Mass Effect Andromeda facial
animations are not the most amazing fire
where have come out and sort of
addressed it with sort of not there is a
new patch from aspect that came out this
week and it addresses a bunch of
different bugs and animation issues but
they aren't seeing whether or not those
animation issues other facial ones
everyone's talking about when bio-oil
asked whether they were going to address
these issues directly they kind of gave
a vague answer where he said they were
going to support this game long term and
then we're gonna listen to fans and
address everything they could address
but we're not a hundred percent sure if
the animations will be changing guess
who has robots
I don't basically everyone that specific
to this news story overwatch I just got
to your character IRISA who was in the
PTR for a long time it's finally in the
live game she's currently not available
for competitive because it kind of just
working out the kinks cuz when summer
ends of a no introduced hey what kind of
broken yeah put committed it and we're
gonna get big lucio changes real soon
Lucy's my boy they're taking him there
what are they doing they're taking away
his heel radius has been Richard yeah 10
min yeah it's really really it's really
talked about like a radius that you can
visibly see even if you're part of the
team you can see where Lucius healing
area okay but also he's wall runs been
buffed so now he get a speed boost boys
on the wall how many jumps up it gets in
the yeah which is like insane cause like
the one thing you don't need lucio to
hat is more speed one thing we've got to
mention is that with his decrease he'll
radius his actual he'll rate actually
went up okay so you can actually heal
through damage cool cool so now when I
say group up with me yeah actually
really need to group of Italy yeah it's
starting to rain like like a lot it's
like really not a little it's not
sprinkling this is the trials with
shooting in the park but we hope you
enjoyed this week's news do subscribe to
us if you liked today's video leave us a
comment telling us what you cared about
this week boy oh boy what I'm gonna see
it we're gonna be on Monday well I'm
gonna go I grade this so that you don't
look why cuz you're embarrassed e kawaii
that's what they say right hello okay
sure yeah hi I'm gonna get over that way
[Music]
yes we got a big game spot following job
ok that's ok you got a camera out and
public people think you're famous whoa